-Welcome to the show, April.
-Wow, you have WBAL.
I'm from Baltimore.
-You are from Baltimore.
And we have our Baltimore
affiliate tonight.
That's just a coincidence.
But I'm glad we -- What's this?
Oh, my God.
-Happy anniversary.
-You got me a cake!
-I got you a cake.
-April.
[ Applause ]
-I sure did.
-Oh, my gosh!
-It's special for someone to be
on the fifth anniversary.
-I know. And yet John Legend
got me nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-I like John Legend.
Leave him alone.
[ Laughter ]
He may be doing battle for me,
you know.
-All right. That's true.
-Yeah.
-All right.
I'm gonna blow it out.
-Make a wish.
-All right, okay.
-There you go.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you're here!
That was my wish.
So I want to start, April,
by saying,
you know,
you cover the White House.
Obviously it became
a very different job
after the election, 2016.
For example, today you were
covering the fact
that the President was tweeting
about Spike Lee
and calling him racist
based on something Spike Lee
said at the Oscars.
Is this beyond your wildest
expectations for where
this would be at this point?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Any and all things presidential
is what I cover.
But I watched the Oscars.
I'm an avid viewer of movies.
I need something mindless
after dealing with
what I deal with every day.
[ Laughter ]
And it's the truth.
And I watched "BlacKkKlansman."
I watched Spike Lee's speech.
And Spike Lee used his script,
or what have you,
his legal pad and paper,
and he spoke about his history.
He spoke about
African-American history.
He didn't call out
the President.
And I'm trying to find where the
President felt it was racist.
And anything the President
tweets, does, says
or is involved in,
that's what we cover.
And unfortunately today
I'm dealing with issues
of Spike Lee and the President.
-You deal with Sarah Sanders
a lot,
although probably less
than you would deal with
most press secretaries because
they don't have daily briefings.
But a few years ago, she tweeted
that she cooked a chocolate
pecan pie for Thanksgiving.
And you wrote,
"Show it to us on a table."
You were basically saying that
it was maybe taken out
of a cookbook or a photo of
not a pie she actually cooked.
But then there was this.
And I will say, you know,
I see the world
in a very different way
than Sarah Sanders.
But I will say, when I saw
this photo, I liked it.
Because I thought,
"Well, this is humanity."
At the end of the day, I do want
to see us all getting along.
-Yes.
-So this was a nice moment.
Yet, is it safe to say that
your relationship with her
has decayed since
this Thanksgiving moment
a couple of years ago?
-It's decayed like that pie,
yes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm gonna get in trouble.
-You're already in trouble.
-That is true.
-Yeah.
-No, but it's -- it's strained.
You know, I believe in trying
to work with an administration.
There's a thing called friendly
adversarial relationship
that Mike McCurry,
the first press secretary
I ever worked with, said.
He was the press secretary
during the Clinton years.
And at issue is
this press secretary
who makes personal attacks
in that briefing room.
When you ask her a legitimate
question
that she doesn't want to answer
or she feels like she is
backed in a corner.
And it's a sad day when
a reporter who is covered by
the First Amendment cannot
legitimately ask a question
without being attacked.
And then once you're attacked,
everyone plasters your face
on certain news organizations
and put targets on your head.
-Yeah.
-So it's a sad day.